Uli Gal Oz!
Thank you so much for joining me
on 20 Minute Leaders.
Thank you very much for hosting me.
Pleasure to be here.
First things first,
there is a jungle behind you.
Talk to me about this jungle.
Okay. So, even before the corona,
we had a
I think that we’re not
living in a sustainable world.
And I have looked
I’ve been looking for ways
to grow my own stuff
in my backyard to have a local,
basically,
almost being like an ...
market. So, grow my stuff.
Okay.
I’ve been vegan for a while
and I looked in the market
for different solutions,
and I found this home-based
AI-driven farm.
It has a place for 30 plants.
And it’s a subscription model
where you get every month
pods with seeds.
And it has everything there,
irrigation, lighting,
camera that takes
a picture of the plants.
And basically, it's done
There’s an app and it turns
on the lights and tells you,
“Hey, you need to fill water.
You need to clean this.
Add some food.”
And I’ve been using it now
for about four months.
- Wow.
- And we’re eating every night
from that small farm because
different kinds of lettuces and spices -
Wow!
oregano and dill, and mint,
and all of that.
I love it. I love it.
And just
One of the most important aspects
of it is it gives you
a great virtual background.
So, you don’t even have to do a -
Exactly. Exactly.
Instead of putting a picture
or a virtual background,
which my computer is too old
it doesn’t allow
I would have needed
a green screen behind me.
So, this is the best
background for me, yeah.
Wonderful. Okay.
Uli, such an
impressive background.
There’s so much to talk about
from your time as an entrepreneur
to business development.
You’ve held multiple CEO positions
and co-founder positions.
But then, you've
handled numerous VP, bizdev,
and head of business positions.
So, I’d love to, you know,
give me a little bit of background
about where you came from
and how you transitioned
from an entrepreneur and CEO
to a sort of the CBO
or VP business development.
Mm-hmm.
So basically, my
I’m an engineer by training.
I went to 8200 in Israel,
to the military.
I’ve been there a few years,
quite a few years.
And got out of there
and basically,
became an entrepreneur.
Started my first company.
It was a technical start-up.
I was CEO, founder/CEO
but also the technology leader.
Ran it for seven years until it ran
to the ground in the 2000 -
Wow
- In the 2000 crash.
Seven years, you’ve worked on it?
Yes.
Wow. What was that like?
How hard was that?
Extremely hard.
There were like two or three
So, I had two acquisition
opportunities that didn’t happen.
One, because of me,
because of hubris,
and the second because of luck.
I had a signed MOU,
basically, a signed agreement
that got rejected by the board
for some reason in political
stuff not related to me.
And two or three near-death
experiences throughout these years.
So, it was a really rough road,
but really interesting.
I think this was my MBA, right?
Basically.
[laughs]
I got down from my
pedestal of hubris
and understood after a few years
that it takes a lot of work
and it’s not you
There is,
of course you have to work hard,
but it’s a lot about
you need to be in the right place
in the right time.
And there’s a huge element
of luck in this road.
So basically, the way I see the
world of technology
entrepreneurship is that you
place a bet on something
that would happen in a few years.
It’s not something that is,
everything that is
totally visible right now,
too late for you for a start-up.
You have to make a bet,
and this bet should be
large enough, but
on the other hand,
not too large that everybody’s
chasing it right now, right.
Right.
So we have basically, it has to be
something outside.
And now the world can either go
that route or not go this route,
and this is something that
is totally out of your control.
So, whatever you do,
you still have to work hard,
but you need to
the world needs to go
your way in a way.
And at least,
I would say 70%, 80%.
And you can pivot,
and so on, and so forth.
But still, in order to really
to succeed, something in the world
has to be happening in your way.
Right. But then, you continue
to be in the CEO positions
for multiple other companies
- Right, right.
So, right. So I
Of course. Basically,
I’m an entrepreneur in my heart.
So, even
even as a VP, bizdev,
I’m doing new businesses, right.
I’m working on new opportunities.
So, the activity is very similar.
It’s basically creating new
products and new business
opportunities that are
open for companies.
I think the main difference
for me was the fact
that you’re
coming into a more mature
company and you
So, just a little bit of less risk.
Right.
But again, I’ve been CEO before.
Like five years ago, I was CEO.
Four and a half years ago.
So, it’s not
I’m not ruling out going back
to doing that.
It’s just a matter of
It’s opportunities,
what comes your way.
And you get attached to something,
you hop into that
into the role.
Right.
So, I’ve been
After that, I went to
after my first company,
I actually said,
“Okay. Now I want to join
to be a CEO of a company
not a founder.”
And so, I joined a company
early-stage as CEO.
And then, I ran it for five years.
Again, grew it from zero, from
to millions of dollars, again.
And then, at some point,
it was sold.
It wasn’t huge success,
but it was sold to an OEM.
And then, I went to another
CEO of another company
in the vision,
in the image analysis space.
Was CEO, got an acquisition offer
that was finally rejected
by the board.
So, I decided to move on.
And then, I got a call from Tango.
So, basically it’s all
In the high tech space, again
because in the early stage
it’s a high stakes,
fast-moving market,
usually in three years,
you know
three, four years, you know,
if this is going the right way
or you understand
where the world is going.
You don’t plan for 20 years.
If you plan your start-up for
20 years from now,
you won’t survive anyway.
So, it’s something that
should happen
like two, three years.
If it doesn’t move
in that direction, you know.
I mean, you know, we’re saying
two, three years but
it doesn’t sound like a lot,
but it is a lot. I mean,
it’s a lot of days.
We’re talking about a thousand
days where you’re basically
you’re scrambling to find
product-market fit to even realize
if this is something worth
pursuing. That takes a lot of grit,
a lot of resilience.
I agree.
And again, and at some point
you realize what’s going on.
In my last CEO position,
it was SleepRate,
which was a sleep
improvement service -
I need that.
- ...consumer health.
Really interesting stuff.
There was a huge issue that
consumers don’t really want to
treat their health, their sleep.
They’re all complaining about it,
but they don’t really treat it,
and especially, they can get
a pill for a dollar,
and they knock themselves out.
It’s much better than
go through a plan
that gives you more holistic -
Yup. Yup.
- It doesn't matter.
So, you fight this fight
and at some point,
you realize that does it work,
doesn’t work.
And what are the
What is the set of dice that
you have in your hands to play and
you know -
- Of course.
So, I think this is
So, for me, again, CEO is,
in the early stages,
CEO is a product manager
and a sales guy,
and an engineering manager,
basically because you have to
make very drastic decisions
about a lot of things.
- Of course.
Now, as the company
moves forward and grows,
the CEO position becomes
more of an operational
Right.
More finances,
more organizational structure,
more cultural.
All the time,
it’s about culture.,
but again early stage culture,
the command of early stage
has to transition
as the company grows into
a more organized, structured
and it’s a different
type of management style.
So, as the companies
become more mature,
for somebody
who’s an entrepreneur,
in his heart
if you join this kind of a company,
you need to be in a position
that you can create.
It’s very creative,
very dynamic environment.
Of course.
And that’s what I’m looking for.
So I don’t know if,
this is my road map
between CEO and VP/BD.
Very, very similar roles, actually.
Interesting.
I didn’t realize that
they were so similar,
but I have to say
that your passion for
the two roles
and their junction just exudes
through the screen.
So, I love it and I’m getting
so much inspiration from this.
Tell me a little bit
about the different VP, BD roles
that you’ve held
and what sort of earned secrets
have you gained over these years
both at Tango, Magisto,
now Moovit.
- Yeah.
Incredible, incredible companies.
Right.
So, I think that the companies
who are consumer-oriented,
very, very consumer-oriented,
have totally different
BD requirements
than companies
that are B2B companies.
And also, by definition,
BD compared to consumer growth,
if you have an arm
of consumer growth
that means internet, playing
with conversion funnels,
and playing with growth hacking.
If this is the company’s
growth strategy,
then BD becomes
who are the right partners
to add to that that will
increase growth or
it’s not revenue usually.
It’s more like how do you grow
faster. How do you grow better?
Right.
Because the end goal
is consumer growth.
And I notice that
in those situations,
there is a very strong gap
between the speed of BD
and the speed of growth.
Okay.
BD by definition
is a slower process.
The partners are usually large,
because otherwise
they cannot move the needle, right?
So, you look for partners
that can move
the needle for you.
And they usually move slowly
You know Verizon, Samsung
Those kinds of guys, they are
even though for them,
half a year is quick.
Right.
And now when you try to do business
development with these guys,
you have now to compare it
to the pivoting approach
of an early-stage startup so -
Exactly.
Early-stage startups pivot
so by the time you finish a deal,
sometimes, it’s just totally
irrelevant because the company
took a spin to a different area.
So, there is a race condition
between the business development
flow, which is a little bit slower
with big partners,
and the path of the company. So -
So, how do you manage
that dissonance because you're
coming into these companies,
as large as they may be,
they’re still start-ups sort of right?
Right.
You’re coming in and you’re working
on these incredible, incredible ideas.
Very creative,
but very transformative
with these huge companies.
And by the time that you get this
approved and you get everything off
the ground, the CEO tells you,
“Eh, Uli, we actually
are doing something else.”
Right. So, I think this is
So, it's frustrating.
Yeah.
It’s part of the role here.
In general, I look at BD
for a start-up
is a very disruptive process
because the product managers
are working on the app on the,
again consumer phase, right.
Working on the app,
they have a road map.
You know, features, adding
new features, building,
stuff like that,
supporting the digital growth.
And suddenly, somebody
comes to them and say,
“We need to do a demo to Samsung"
Okay, so now, you have to
they need to divert resources.
They need
And then, "When is it coming?"
"I don’t know.
Maybe in six months.
And actually, I’m going to give
you 10 of those,
and one of them
would happen because nine,
you know, they don’t happen."
Yeah.
So, basically
it’s a disruptive process,
but it’s very important
because you understand
how the market
So, there is a significant learning
from those experiences
because you understand
what they are looking for,
how they see the market
and it helps the product team,
the engineering,
management team of the company
to really take a look and see,
"Okay, this is how the world
looks at this problem."
As a start-up,
we’re really focused on driving
something that we believe in.
In reality, not necessarily
lives ...
There is a distortion by definition, right?
There’s a distortion in the vision.
Or the vision
is disruptive to the world.
And so but you don’t see
the world in many cases
because you’re so closed view.
And so, I think
So one of the roles is
the BD brings in
perspectives that are not
existent otherwise.
Totally.
- And you know
sometimes,
it does help even though
So, not every time there is
a 90% pivot, right?
Or sometimes,
it’s like a 10% pivot.
And then, it helps.
I mean it’s all, it grows.
It helps the maturation
of the business.
So, what would you say
are some of the top traits
that a good VP of business
development need to have
in order to be successful
both at young companies
but also-late stage?
So, I would say for
for technology companies.
Yeah.
I think there is a need to have
it’s a mix of technology
understanding.
You have to understand
technology because there’s a
If you’re not a technologist
and you come to do business,
it’s very hard because you need to
close gaps between what you have
in the technology
and what they look for.
There is a
So, this gap is a technology gap in some cases
that you need understand.
- Sure.
Otherwise, you'll just sell
some ...
something that is not realistic.
So, you have to have
technology understanding.
If you
Second is that you need to be
to understand business models.
Right.
There is a
There are so many
I mean, the world now is so
complicated in terms of different
ways to make money,
and to get success.
So, there is a,
there is that part of the
understanding so
And the last one is really
creativity and flexibility.
Basically you have
to be a listener, right,
because you need to understand
what is the partner looking for
and what you have.
And this is something
that sometimes is subtle.
Sometimes, they don’t really
understand exactly what it means.
So, you have to make
this translation of what you have
to what they need.
And this is a
It has a lot of
Usually, it’s very creative,
very,
listening, you have
to be listening
very, very hard to what problem
they are trying to solve.
Right.
And then there is the internal sales,
which is huge challenge as well.
You have to sell,
not only to the partner,
you have to come in
and convince
the internal group whether
that it makes sense to actually go
after this opportunity because,
again, it’s disruptive to
the normal flow of business.
So, it’s a tough position,
but I think it’s very dynamic,
very people-oriented.
So, it combines technology,
business, market and insights,
product.
It’s actually encompassing
a lot of disciplines.
So, very fun.
Right. So you know,
one of the key questions
that I come across when I think
of business development is,
looking at myself
as a young entrepreneur,
I’m gonna start my own venture.
How do I know when I need to start
having somebody else on the team
that has this entrepreneurial
mindset and corporate understanding
to know when to do this
business development?
So, at what point do I say,
“Okay, the company is now
on a certain mission,
and I need this external factor
or this X factor within my company
to go and to think about these
new corporate developments?"
I think that the real
So, I would say two scenarios.
One, you have
you've hit product market fit.
And now, you’re into growth
and into driving stuff.
That’s a good time
to make this addition.
because then,
You need to grow. You need to
You need to have partners to push.
You also understand what kind of
partners you’re looking
in many cases
as opposed to young
Before that, you’re just running
around to try to understand what
is the product
that you are selling.
In some cases,
when you bring somebody like that
too early, and could happen,
then basically, if you are very
strong in your vision,
then it would be a distraction.
It wouldn’t work.
Right.
If you are open and you say,
"Okay, let’s take this kind of a
talent as one of the ways to test
the market and to reach
for that market fit"
If this is what you’re looking for,
then you can do it really early.
But it really depends
on how you’re
Basically what your preference is
in terms of do you want
to run the business
you know exactly what you want.
It’s more of a CEO trait.
You know, if the CEO says,
“I know. I have a vision.
I know where I’m going.
Don’t disrupt me.
Don’t give me other
Too much noise.
I need to be focused.”
At that point,
don’t bring anybody else because
it will be disruptive.
It will be annoying
and noisy by definition.
The minute
either, you know
again, so
I think I gave you
A hundred percent.
It sounds complicated.
It sounds like it’s an art
and that there’s no right answer.
It sounds like you have every
to each his own.
And even
once you employ a certain strategy,
you don’t know what the other
outcome would have been.
But it takes a lot of understanding
and a lot of open-mindedness
to go along that route.
And definitely,
the one takeaway that I’m taking
from this is this idea that you
have to find a balance
at the end about everything.
You have to be focused
on your mission.
You have to be open-minded to
different developments because
it’s not just about your growth,
but it’s about the missed
opportunities that you might have
in the market. If you’re a disruptor
in the market and you have others
that are around the
same time as you.
There’s only
there’s a cake and you want a good
slice of that cake
with the best partners.
So, Uli, thank you
for all that inspiration.
I have one last question
because 20 minutes are almost up,
and I can’t believe it
every single time.
What are three words
that you would use
to describe yourself?
I would say creative, honest
Creative, honest -
and energetic.
I love it.
It sounds like
that’s pretty much
what you need
to be good a vice president
of business development.
Uli, best of luck in Moovit.
I love following everything
that you’re doing.
It’s so impressive
and so inspiring.
Thank you for your time.
Thank you!
Take care.